let me start animating please note that
this meeting will be audio recorded
should we require to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
by the door he said by the delorean to
the fire escape staircase please hold
both handrails in case the stairs always
or slippery if anyone is unable to use
the stairs would they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
then be given assistance our assembly
point will be in the public our pockets
side of the ceiling sweet please do not
delay your evacuation to reflect any
belongings and she's a Nocturne to the
audience if given permission to do so by
council staff used to be five of those
anymore right so let's doesn't be due to
be that apologies for absence I believe
there are any thank you non members
attending a bleeder are only right
minutes of the meeting of the on the old
on the fourth of February's if I wish I
signed as a true record every Ranger
thank you any declarations of interest
if anything comes up doing the mix and
please do write it at that time pass and
refer to the attentive reports from
other communities that blew their own
none right got straight into elephant's
ass basis strategy please and the kids
got much this I've got this two minor
amendments trim I can advise I need to
take a count or which will be done yet
would you like to another Idol to the
report ready do you know what the minor
amendments are yes sorry this one is
that paragraph nine point fourteen a
will page that please
6.3 sony a strange that's not a nice be
deleted as it's repeating something
later in in reports and also at nine
point 16 b which is at six flag 38 we
need to amend the word hockley to read
hockley woods as the alternate also
excuse me sir and it was an intersect
kappa with a challenge but allah street
district yes the other you said the
details are okay right otherwise Joan
this has been out for consultation like
the point was previously this is the
result of consultations so now I is
executive to finally get a rubber stamp
so there can be official document
mazzara I'm explosive strength you okay
any other comments please all questions
I'm sorry did banana okay does it take
to say nothing to do with a strategy I
thing but just promise and reach our
point of view on 6.6 which is paid for
the strategy open spaces team and
civility to get things done says we we
will ensure that staff have the correct
knowledge so notionally if we haven't
given them the correct knowledge then
they won't be able to do the job I
wonder whether there should be a caveat
word we will strive to ensure something
like that nothing to do with the
strategy just my age our point of view
can I come back in the lead in certain
cases we cannot allow them to do the
work yes they have the adequate
knowledge when it comes into things like
change so yeah yeahs only lies have yet
acknowledged to actually complete with
their job and it is a prerequisite that
they
kind of have that soda they can carry on
just I think well I'd say is trying to
be helpful be the word aim is is at the
top of the page so I think these are
aims they're not necessarily guarantee
set in stone but you know clearly I
accept the point that we we don't try to
ensure the staff are equipped to be able
to deal with all the issues meditate now
it would reasonable comes into this
doesn't it yeah okay well thank you for
that any other points so members do
recommend the report approach thank you
right item 17 it's a timetable of
meetings anybody wish any comments on
the timetable of meetings having studied
it vigorously no dated anybody EO usual
said knows I think this comes up again
doesn't it i think when we start the new
year yeah its chairman of ordinary
councils will need to be agreed at
annual council in New Year this program
covers the regulatory committees and the
licensing committees is with witness
counsel and executive okay so there'll
be a second diately cheering they're all
members okay um right so book report
we're approved there's no come in and
cruelly keeper quite that fishy closures
the meeting japanese war Martin isn't
brothers three executive not on do it
yes brink it we don't need to agree one
for the special exec to dismiss